Fractional exponents can be
a little daunting at first,
so it never hurts to do as
many examples as possible.
So let's do a few.
What if we had
25/9, and we wanted
to raise it to the 1/2 power?
So we're essentially
just saying, well,
what is the principal
square root of 25/9?
So what number times
itself is going to be 25/9?
Well, we know 5 times 5
is 25, and 3 times 3 is 9.
So why don't we
just go with 5/3?
Because notice, if you
have 5/3 times 5/3,
that is going to be 25/9.
Or another way of saying
this, that 5/3 squared
is equal to 25/9.
So 25/9 to the 1/2 is
going to be equal to 5/3.
Now let's escalate
things a little bit.
Let's take a really hairy one.
Let's raise 81/256 to
the negative 1/4 power.
I encourage you to pause this
and try this on your own.
So what's going on here?
This negative-- the first
thing I always like to do
is I want to get rid of this
negative in the exponent.
So let me just take
the reciprocal of this
and raise it to the positive.
So I could just say that
this is equal to 256/81
to the 1/4 power.
And so now I can say,
well, what number
times itself times
itself times itself
is going to be equal
to 256, and what number
times itself times
itself times itself--
did I say that four times?
Well, what number, if I take
four of them and multiply,
do I get 81?
And one way to
think about it, this
is going to be the
same thing-- and we'll
talk about this in
more depth later
on when we talk about
exponent properties.
But this is going to be
the exact same thing as 256
to the 1/4 over 81 to the 1/4.
You, in fact, saw it over here.
This over here was the same
thing as the square root of 25
over the square root of 9.
Or 25 to the 1/2
over 9 to the 1/2.
So we're just doing
that over here.
So one, we still have to think
about what number this is.
And this is a little bit of,
there's no easy way to do this.
You kind of have
to just play around
a little bit to come up with it.
But 4 might jump out at you if
you recognize that 16 times 16
is 256.
We know that 4 to
the fourth power,
or you're about to know this,
is 4 times 4 times 4 times 4.
And 4 times 4 is 16, times 4
is 64, times 4 is equal to 256.
So 4 to the fourth
is 256, or we could
say 4 is equal to
256 to the 1/4 power.
Fair enough?
Now what about 81?
Well, 3 might jump out at you.
We know that 3 to
the fourth power
is equal to 3 times 3 times 3
times 3, which is equal to 81.
So 3 is equal to 81 to the 1/4.
So this top number, 256
to the 1/4, that's just 4.
81 to the 1/4, that is just 3.
So this right over here is
going to be equal to 4/3.